foreign
Cypress what's up Nicole how we doing
hi Dr deloni how's it going
I'm good how are you good good good good
what's up
um so when I initially wrote in it was
um
little mother with no Village
um I guess I struggle a lot I have a
three-year-old and a two-year-old okay
and their dad is not in the picture he
we decided on how starting a family and
then I guess once my son was born about
three months into it I found out that
it was being unfaithful so you know that
was right before that was actually right
before the pandemic started so then we
were stuck inside a one-bedroom
apartment with a newborn and just
nowhere to go because it was a big
shutdown over here in California well
everywhere but you know where I am but a
lot in California yeah yeah so
um it was hard and
I guess since then you know it's
I think we try to like kind of make it
work and everything and then it didn't
so we separated ways and ever since we
have not lived together which was in
um
I get little less and less support from
him and then I guess it's just become
more and more toxic because I think he
just walks in and out whenever he wants
so is there no is there no custody
Arrangement did y'all go to court
we didn't
um okay you need to do that
I know and I know you don't want to but
you need to do that and and if even if
you don't think enough of yourself to do
it for you in your safety in your
um Economic Security down the road
with your kids
yeah feel for your kids
so I guess like I struggle because and I
I have them like 99 of the time he sees
them a few hours a couple days a week
um until it's a season where he decides
he wants to show up and be more frequent
uh but most of the time listen that's
destroying those kids
I know stop
yeah
do you are you still intimate with him
you still sleep with him every once in a
while
no
um when's the last time we all were
together
um like in
like it was a
because he he said he wanted to
no no you don't give me because you
don't do because I'm not trying to do it
to shame you I'm trying to
I'm trying to at some point you're
getting something out of this too
and it's not sexually like that
there's this profound loneliness
in this profound you had a picture of
what life was going to be like with two
kids and a family and y'all agreed on it
and I don't think you've let that
picture go yet and you're still trying
to hang on
and every time he pops in and out of
that picture you're like oh there it is
it could happen it could happen and then
he comes in in the summer and he's like
hey let's make this thing work
and then you feel used and the whole you
see what I'm saying yeah
the picture's over
and what the world and your kids are
desperate for Nicole is for you to to
draw something new
okay
is that fair tell me I'm wrong man tell
me you're gonna make this thing work
no I I mean I have gotten no contact
with him for a while now so it's just
been you know I guess I guess I fear
when he does try to do it you know again
because recently he's
I mean I did file like I had to file a
restraining order
um oh so you've no contact ordered him
like so you've you've been yeah go
through the paperwork
yeah so yeah and then they just they
just were able to serve him recently for
the child support papers and
stuff I guess the child I mean not child
support yeah child support but not the
we haven't done custody stuff so we all
legally divorced are we all ever legally
married
no we were never legally married okay
okay yeah go through the go go through
the paperwork process and clear some of
these lines up
and when you do that
it's gonna be
so relieving
and it's gonna be devastating at the
same time and I want you to expect both
of those okay
the relief of
everybody's on the same page now the
chances he pays if you look at the data
across the country are low
okay right the chances that he just
doesn't show up on a Tuesday anyway
you're gonna have to follow those things
to a T
okay follow things to a T I was working
with somebody recently um privately
who's
um
showed up and like whose kids out of
town showed up at night uh the night
before and just called their spouse and
said hey
um can I go ahead and take so and so our
kid out to dinner
I know custody doesn't start I mean I
know my visitation starts in the morning
caused a whole just follow it to a
letter follow to the letter to the
letter to the letter but you got to get
in writing you got to get it written
down you got to get a judge to sign off
on it
and then there's going to be a finality
because you're gonna go look at that
picture at that canvas and it's going to
be completely blank and it's going to be
terrifying
like the kids I guess
um is what I worry about the most like
they're fought like you know they see
them you know have a few hours a week
you know twice a week
um and they really enjoy those times and
but it's magic time it's not real
right he gets to play superhero he gets
to show up and give him Chick-fil-A
McDonald's and ice cream and play for a
couple hours and be the cool
rambunctious guy then he gets to
disappear
yeah and you have to do math homework
and you have to do bedtimes and you have
to do bath times so it's it's it's it's
not real time their experiences with him
are
uh I mean they're they're they're a
vapor
so
I found out because we agreed that he
wouldn't take him to his apartment
because he lives with a male roommate
um you know they're in there I think
he's in his 30th single um I'm not
saying anything's wrong with that but he
does have like friends over and I just
worry about you know the risk you should
all of it okay listen Nicole somewhere
along the way somebody told you that
that that voice in your guts should just
shut up
and I'm telling you for the for the
first time in a long time you got to
start trusting your gut you gotta listen
to that voice because it knows
it knows you know what's going on in
that apartment Nicole you've known that
dude for a long time
you know
right so yeah
you should you should that's what I'm
telling you go get the paperwork done
and how are the kids going to be like if
they have to go through a season without
seeing their dad it's gonna be hard
until that but listen he left y'all
he left y'all
and it's gonna be worse when they're in
Middle School
and he says things like I don't know man
your mom just took you away and you're
gonna have to deal with that crap too
here's what you're doing you're playing
a 25-year game with him now
are they boy girl what are they
I have a friend and daughter okay
a little boy is going to be wondering
what in the world he did to send Dad
away
and that little girl's gonna wonder what
was so beautiful about somebody else
and daddy wanted to be with him and not
mommy and me
unfortunately those you you
letting him come in and out of your life
is not gonna answer those questions for
those kids
it's gonna be a long game of you showing
up and showing up and showing up and
showing up and showing up
and when they look back they'll go oh
golly dang dude
but in the in the me in the meantime you
can't expect an 11 year old a
six-year-old a nine-year-old a 15 year
old to not want to go where the cool
stuff's happening
dad's cool roommates and you know what I
mean that's where every kid's gonna want
to go there
that's where they need an adult in their
life that says hey I love you enough to
say no I love you enough to give you
some stability some safety
and unfortunately dad's not playing that
game
foreign
[Applause]
what this also means is you're gonna
have to get some people in your life
you're gonna have to get a couple of
girlfriends that you trust deeply that
you can email that you can text you can
call that will come over the middle of
the night that will go out and hang out
with you
you're gonna have to get those folks in
your life you can't do this by yourself
not for not forever
I haven't done anything by myself you
know for myself well other than like a
shower and I guess get my nails done yes
yes listen you you you think that's
normal now
and I'm smiling like as though we're
hanging out like I would be laughing and
you would be laughing you think nine
minutes under hot hot water
is your R and R time
it's not
and maybe no one's ever told you this
but you are worth so much more
and by the way my friend will uh guadera
who's a restaurant here in New York he
tells his staff this when he when he uh
he tells his staff he always is telling
them
his weight staff you cannot fill up
other people's pictures of other
people's glasses if your picture's empty
if you want to really serve your
customers well you got to go in the back
room and fill up your pictures and only
then can you fill up your the the
customer's glasses same principle
applies to you Mom all you single moms
out there
you can't fill up your little kids
glasses
unless your picture's full and I know oh
God I know like oh you privileged you're
just I know I know I know it's hard for
me to hear that from me I get that 100
good call up
I'm telling you
the greatest gift you can give your life
when dad walks out on them is a well Mom
is a mom who believes in herself enough
and loves herself enough to demonstrate
to those kids here's what self-care
looks like here's what love looks like
here's what laughter and joy looks like
y'all are worth those things you're
worth those things Nicole
hang on the line here I'm gonna send you
a copy of my book on your past change
your future I want you to read it once
you do the exercises in it and then I
want you to call me back and we can talk
through here's what we do next here's
where we go from here
but I want you to call the courts let's
get this thing in writing let's get the
the custody Arrangement down you've
you've had the no contact order you've
taken care of the child support stuff
let's go ahead and do this all the way
let's get some people in our life in
your life that will walk alongside you
and if you don't have anybody it's gonna
be awkward and weird because making
friends as an adult is the worst but
you're worth it
every step of the way call me anytime
Nicole anytime